en el 2000 termine de ser embajador aquí
en costa rica
y me volví a la argentina
yo tengo más de 25 años de trabajar en
política en la argentina
y entonces tuve la alternativa de que
hacer había sido ministro de la
patagonia
durante siete años
y entonces tenía algunas alternativas
una era de ellas seguir en política pero
me di cuenta que se les iba a necesitar
mucha plata para hacer política y que en
esa mucha plata que se iba a necesitar
estaba la matriz de corrupción
nadie le pone atención a este tema todos
ven el resultado de la corrupción y dije
esto no es para mí algunos amigos que sí
se quedaron en en la política
hoy están en la cárcel en argentina
entonces yo dije esto no es para mí y
buscó otras alternativas
en argentina los abogados podemos hacer
de todos no sé si acá también
entonces otra alternativa que tenía era
meterme en la economía pero dije está
bien esto viene difícil y también tuve
razón hoy el dólar esta mañana en
argentina pegó un salto del 16 por
ciento
el riesgo-país se fue al 730
aproximadamente por no atender lo que
gerardo decía con relación a los
sísmicos
al principio de todo esto y entonces que
que hice tenía otra alternativa d
devolverme a costa rica y reinventarme
espero que no saquen la cuenta pero
tenía 60 años y dije me reinvento
todo es posible en esta vida y en busca
de la excelencia también en esa
reinvención me compré un bandoneón y
aprendí solo si es que aprendí aquí en
costa rica ustedes dirán que es la
humildad que nos caracteriza a los
argentinos soy el mejor bandoneonista en
aquí en costa rica porque no hay otro y
espero seguir así durante mucho tiempo
así que por favor no le digan a nadie
que venga a costar dedica a hacer todo
esto que yo estoy haciendo y entonces me
reinventé y entonces me puse a dar
clases de tango porque identifique que
la vida
cuesta poco vivir
sencillamente feliz uno puede llegar a
muchos lados y entonces tome el tango
sigo haciendo programas de radio desde
aquí para la argentina dos programas de
radio de análisis de economía de todo el
mundo por suerte donald trump me da
motivo todos los días con el último
twitter que hace
putin también angela merkel ni que
hablar macro también y entonces vivo
realmente feliz haciendo esto que lo
tome con la profundidad que tiene el
tango porque como diría un poeta buenos
aires- más me das y más te debo yo soy
nacido aquí buenos aires- mis hijos mis
amigos son de allá allá mis sueños
siguen esperando la música de allá se
llama tango tango es regresar al punto
cardinal tango es un beso en el andén en
la oficina o en
en vez de pura vida y tiene tango la
mujer de una mansión pero también
compartir la tos en un bullying de dos
por dos y aquí como me ves buenos aires
mi tango es sin guapos y sin puñal
comienza maestro cuando empieza cada
aurora es que mi tango ocurre aquí aquí
y ahora
[Música]
i
e
no más
y
[Música]
hoy
i
[Música]
y
e
[Música]
o no
e
[Música]
bien
y un genio del del tango aquel que llevó
la música del tango a niveles de música
clásica astor piazzolla hizo un tema
hermoso tema que se llama oblivion
oblivion quiere decir abandono pero el
otro día un costarricense que saben más
de tango que yo muchos me dijo que
quería decir abandono sin memoria que es
un poquito más fuerte para todos ustedes
oblivion
hermoso tema
[Música]
pero
i
[Música]
no
y
[Música]
un día
i
[Música]
muy bien
verdad
y
[Música]
i
no
[Música]
y
dv
[Música]
sí
él
[Música]
hermoso tema
y para terminar y para terminar esos
compases anuncian aquel aquel tango
que lo hizo un talentos uruguayo gerardo
matos rodríguez hizo un tema que para
una comparsa no pasó mucho y como
siempre pasa lo arreglo un argentino y
humildemente para ser coherente en todo
y fue convertido en el himno del tango y
aquel tango que era para una comparsa y
se llamó entonces la cumparsita
ya ves
[Música]
él
baby
[Música]
m
ah
[Música]
e
pero
y
y él
[Música]
e
y
sí
[Música]
y
gracias
mercedes y alexis fuerte el aplauso para
ellos muchas gracias
[Música]